وكل دقيقه بحساب كل ثانيه بنفس كل انين
اشاره كل صوت بشاره كل سكون نهايه هكذا
يمر الوقت ثقيلا بطيئا في الامل وسريعا في
العمل على عمل الانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا
وهم يحيطون باكام الدمار في سباق على
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه يرخون السمع علهم
يرصدون نبض حياه وهم يتسلقون ما كانت قبل
ساعات غرفه نوم او مطبخ او معيشه ما كانت
حياه كامله
انقضت وامام الردم يتجمع اهالي العالقين
بامل ينفتح امامهم عند كل هتاف او تصفيق
باخراج احياء بينما يجلس اخرون بلا حيله
يتخيلون من كانوا ورحلوا في لحظات بانقضاء
اكثر من 60 ساعه تتراجع الامال بايجاد
ناجين يتحدث الخبراء الاطباء عن قاعده
الاربعه حيث يمكن للانسان ان يعيش اربع
دقائق دون هواء واربعه ايام دون ماء
واربعه اسابيع دون طعام ان كان ذا بنيه
قويه لكن القواعد تصطدم بايات الاجال فترى
اخراج رضيع لم يتجاوز عمره اياما وصغار
وكبار ربما ساعدهم في النجاه وضعهم
ومكانهم خلال الزلزال او لوجود منفذ لماء
او هواء في كل الحالات يزيد عدد الضحايا
ويكبر مع الوقت بوتيره سريعه مع تقلص امال
النجاه وفي الوجه الاخر للماساه تتعاظم
تحديات مواجهه النكبه الانسانيه لمن باتوا
بلا ماوى وهم بمئات الالاف في البلدين
الفزعه العالميه لنجده الضحايا تواصلت لكن
في شمال سوريا حيث يختلط الحزن بالاستغاثه
بحفر الارض باليدين في غياب
ورافعات حديثه يقول دفاع المدني ان الامال
تتضائل بالعثور على احياء وان المستشفيات
العاجزه اصلا قد بلغت اقصى قدرتها الوضع
الماساوي يتطلب مساعدات والمساعدات عالقه
في سراديب السياسه وتعقيدات الوضع السوري
الذي لم يجد فيه مجلس الامن ما يستدعي
جلسه طارئه لفتح المعابر الخاضعه لاليه
دوليه بقرار منه حيث تمر المساعدات عبر
تركيا واعلنت الامم المتحده الخميس ادخال
ست شاحنات اغاثه غذائيه وطبيه من معبر باب
الهوى وقال مسؤولون السوريون ان جزءا منها
كان مبرمجا من قبل وكلها تبقى ضئيله تكاد
لا ترى امام هول الكارثه في الجانب التركي
تجاوز عدد فرق الانقاذ الدوليه سته الاف
من 56 دوله فيما اقر البرلمان فرض حاله
الط في عشر ولايات منكوبه هي اضنه وايدي
يامان وديار بكر وهاتاي وعثمانيه
وغازي عنتاب انه اليوم الرابع وكل ما في
المشهد خالق كان الارض صغرت الى كومه حطام
هناك حيث يجلس احياء ينتظرون والباقي من
الزمن قليل